e
e e
morning everyone I'm going to call the
executive session of the house Judiciary
Committee to order and would you first
please uh rise and join me in the pledge
of
allegiance to the repic for it stands
one nation God indivisible with liberty
and justice for all but I also ask if
you just take a moment silence to
recognition of the aine tragedy that
happened Washington
last thank you
um right so um the first order of
business I'm going to take up is um it's
it's basically a doover to correct
really what what was uh a mistake on my
part um you will recall that we have
already exact voted on and sent reports
to uh the clerk on House Bill 98 and
House Bill 164 FN and those were both
unanimous votes of uh the committee um
unfortunately we did that executive
session when we had already placed a
notice in the calendar saying we would
do that today I think there might be an
issue that technically we might be all
right because the we might have actually
held the executive session before it got
put in the calendar but that's
questionable Paul clerk rightly wants to
make sure all the eyes are dotted and
the te's are cross and so for that
reason um he requested and I agree that
we should revote on uh uh on House Bill
98 and on 164 so I'm going to uh uh
reopen so um on 164 the amendment that
updates the fiscal note is actually
ready it's upstairs in the office do you
want me to bring that down this was
something we're going to deal with in
finance but if we're doing this over
again we can just yeah can so I'll I'll
you know what we'll I I'll take up this
one and I may go on to some other on
that sounds great go all right so first
I'll take up
98 um that's relative to uh professional
limited
liability uh company assistant managers
um we have previously passed that OTP
but I will recognize representative tur
for a motion of ought to pass I'd like
to make a motion of OTP on House Bill 98
there a
second second by representative Perez is
there any further discussion on House
Bill
98 all right then I would ask the uh
clerk to call the role can you give the
clerk a minute oh of course yes yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely no problem
take no take your time take your time
I'm
oh yeah I don't know
she maybe she got maybe she got you know
kid kid issues or something like that
didn't say yeah no she didn't say
anything to me
yeah yeah K okay all
right that was
quick all
right yeah I didn't even see you
leave all right you go
[Laughter]
back all right
right well you know what um I'm 90 we
don't have to do that on 98 though do we
16 it's on yeah only on 90 on 90 I will
reopen on 164 but 98 so U all right so
um whenever you're ready for the
question is yeah I'm I'm not gonna have
okay I just want to make sure so you
know what representative U cutab I'm
gonna we're gonna we're about to take a
vote on something that you will not be
able to vote on because we already
called the vote I'll explain to it's no
big deal I'll explain the sit I'll
explain the situation to you once we
take the vote and then you can vote on
the next one all right um so I ask the
clerk then to call the role of the
motion is OTP on House Bill 98
representative Manion yes representative
Alexander yes representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes
represent representative Perez
yes clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
yes where
Mor representative Smith yes
representative Horgan yes representative
Manos oh sorry sorry representative
Harvey yes representative Raymond yes
representative Manos yes representative
tur yes representative Rambo yes and
representative buron
yes you guys
representative Lynn yes chairman Lynn
sorry that's all
right 16 Ys zero
Nays second so this was
uh it 17 no becauseit couldn't
called she and represented Morton is not
here oh
good question a good question
OTP
um what is it 17 to zero 16 16
Z okay
um uh this no this uh any any
objection any objection to this going on
the consent calendar on
98 no objection it'll go on
consent oh and uh and um representative
uh Smith you already filed your report
which is uh which is perfectly a
perfectly good report you were you were
absolutely absolutely all right now um
now for for the for um representative
kab uh you know you know what right so
all right so I'm going to then
reopen um the hearing on
HB
164 relative to local records um and I'm
going to uh
recognize um representative Alexander
for a motion thank you Mr chair I move
HB 164 ought to pass and I offer
Amendment 2025 0087 each uh is there a
second second second by representative
tur um
just briefly this amendment um is what I
mentioned during um the public hearing
this was the Secretary of State's office
just wanted an update a fiscal note for
this year um I was going to offer it in
finance but because we're doing a doover
vote um here I
am CH representative
CH hang on one second
um
all right so um we need to
um anybody let me ask this anybody have
anything else they want to say on the
amendment uh it's 20
for a show of hands if you're in favor
of the amendment um please raise your
hand anyone
opposed no uh is no one having indicated
opposition it passes
unanimously um so
now
um what is that uh so what's it 18 no we
have 17 17 Z
all right all right so now um the uh
chair U again recognize representative
Alexander for motion of OTP to pass is
amended all right is there a
second second second by representative
Smith and
all right um anybody have anything else
they want to say on the motion uh of
otpa on uh HB 164 FN seeing none I asked
the clerk when you're when you're ready
to call the roles thank you
representative Manion yes representative
Alexander representative trip yes
representative Andrew yes representative
kutab yes representative Perez yes clerk
votes yes M representative
McFarland yes representative Smith yes
representative Horgan yes representative
Harvey yes representative Raymond yes
representative Manos yes representative
tur yes representative Rambo yes
representative berson yes represent
chairman Lynn yes
17 yays zero Nays yeah yeah did you you
said you you voted yes too right I
that's y all right all right um so now
next um I will turn to um who's the
author auth um Mr chair I already have a
report written but I'll send you an
updated one with the amendment language
oh that's fine sure yeah yeah yeah and
um can you can you get you think you can
get that to me by tonight good all right
good this go this this will have to go
on the regular calendar because it's
going to finance
um yeah
um okay
um all right all right then let me turn
to um HB um 111
FN there was a small error in the
amendment which I just I just got the
corrected one from OS and I was asking
if Karen or Kristen might be able to
help thank you so much um yeah we'll
pass we we we'll pass on that one for a
minute okay all right thank you um then
let me move to um
hr6 uh house resolution condemning the
judicial doctrine of uh Des dispert
impact and the chair recognizes
representative Manos for a motion thank
you Mr chair uh on on hr6 I would move
itl right is there a
second a second it second by rep Oh
seconded by representative trip on one
second
um okay all right um representative
Manos would you like to speak to your
motion thank you Mr chair um Mr chair uh
I I recommended itl on this um on this
HR for several reasons the doctrine of
uh disparate impact is a Judicial uh
Doctrine and and I don't think that the
legislature can bind can bind the
Judiciary on decisions about disparate
impact but in addition to that I think
that um although the Judiciary May um
use disparate impact improperly in some
cases I think that this HR uh paints too
broad a brush and for that reason I
would recommend to the committee itl on
this HR all right thank you anyone else
wish to speak representative organ um I
mean I I not sure if I understood all of
it but um it aside from the merits of
having an HR in this at all like it
presumably needed more work when he had
his written testimony on it was much
more detailed and um it was a little it
was like a little more understandable um
and also there was a drafting ER in here
they going to send it they should just
said to the governor of New Hampshire
and the identity the governor of New
Hampshire changed between when he
submitted it and uh when he when we
considered it so it is in fact Kelly iot
rather than Chris the newo so I think
even if we wanted to move forward it
would need an extensive Amendment so um
so I gra support the itl but I
congratulate him and his uh wife on on
their new baby so that's that's good
thanks all right anyone else wish to be
heard on hr6 so I guess what I what the
only thing I would say on hr6 is as um
I think that there are that there are
problems with the doctrine of disparate
impact and that it at as it has been
used uh by the courts in various places
at both the federal and state level I
think it's it's been used
inappropriately in many cases but I
don't think it's true that it's been
used inappropriately in all cases
and this um HR really to me paints with
just two brought a brush number one and
number two I just uh you know as a
general
proposition um I I'm I question the
value of HRS anyway I mean which
basically it's not a it's not a law it's
just sort of
us you know saying something and uh at
at the very least if we're going to say
it I think it ought to be it ought to be
really accurate and I'm I'm with
deference to the author of this of this
I don't I think it's it's just it it's
it paints something that's that's more
complicated with with with sort of too
broad a brush and oversimplify so I'm
I'm also uh in favor of itl anyone else
uh wish to be
heard all right then I guess we're ready
for a vote on hr6 uh on the motion of
itl Representative Manion yes
representative trip
yes no sorry representative Alexander
yes representative Andrew yes
representative
cutab yes representative Perez
no clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
no representative Smith yes
representative Horgan yes representative
Harvey yes representative Raymond yes
representative Manos yes representative
tur yes representative Rambo yes
representative berson yes and chairman
Lynn
yes 15 Ys two
Nays two all right all right um and um
this so um well let me ask first um with
15-2 i i this could go on the consent C
anybody object to it going on
consent all right so it'll be on
consent um and I would ask
representative
Manos um can you provide the and um can
you provide that to me by the end by
tonight well as long as some as long as
yeah as long as long as I get it so that
I can you know first thing in the
morning can look at it thank you uh all
right report all right is there going to
be a Minority Report I assume it's not
on consent okay no all right
and okay all right
all
right all right so representative katab
whenever you are ready on the on 111 we
can oh you are ready okay all right um
so then I'm I'm going to uh as a next
matter of business I'm going to turn to
uh
hb11 of uh FN extending the position of
the right to know on budsman for years
and I recognize representative katab for
a
motion I move a to pass with Amendment
d178 second okay all
right
um all right and representative katab
would you like to speak to your motion
uh first dealing with the amendment
would you like to speak to the
amend so we heard about a few issues
with the udman office in the testimony
although overwhelmingly we heard much
great testimony
and one of the issues that was really
concerning to there were two issues that
were really concerning to me and the
first one was it seemed as if kind
of law fair so to speak was being used
to dissuade parties from filing with the
um budsman and so when they were filing
certain municipalities were
threatening
um or or turning the other party in
or their friend for unauthorized
practice of law when they were getting
um help from somebody but there was
no
[Music]
um exchanging of fees
whatsoever um and so it it just wasn't
right it was it was it was really
dissuading parties from running and the
other the other piece was that
um they were also threatening you know
basically asking for for attorney fees
from the municipality and this was
really supposed to be more of like a
citizen to Citizen type of an office
where you're not going through court and
so if one party is choosing to to use an
attorney that's fine but the other party
then shouldn't be expected that they're
going to have to pay for the other
party's attorney fees and you know if
the other party should Prevail so this
is just simply preventing these two
issues that we heard about from
happening I think it's important that we
make the office access to people without
fear of these kind of I
guess uh retribution or negative action
so to
speak anyone else have anything they
want to say on we're talking about the
amendment now anybody else have anything
they want to say um on the amendment Bob
um before I say what I'm thinking on the
amendment let me just ask the the motion
is as I heard it that we Mo we move
ought to pass with Amendment rather than
merely adopting the amendment can we
split the question and vote on the
amendment first that's yeah that's what
that's what we are that's we're we're
going to vote on the amendment first and
then you know if depending on the
outcome of that then we would vote on
the on the main bill so um the uh so the
ISS the question before us now is um is
on the amendment anybody else have
anything they else they want to say on
the
amendment all right so again because
this is an amendment I think we don't
have to have a roll call vote on this I
mean obviously I should say if anybody
wants a roll call vote we'll have a roll
call vote but I don't think we need to
have one um and so what I would ask is
on
Amendment uh
2025 0170 H can I see a show of hands of
all those in favor of the amendment
please raise your
hand anyone oppos to the amendment all
right so the amendment is um on the
amendment the vote
is 16 to1 all right there were two I'm
sorry two o who's the other
opposed Oregon and mcfar and mcfar I'm
sorry oh he was fine oh you're for the
all right so it's just representative H
all right hang
on K
kaitz second
16 all right so uh the amendment um is
adopted and now um the issue before us
is uh is uh otpa and I recognize uh
representative kutab do you anything you
want to say on anything further you want
to say
no that's okay all right any yes
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair um while I do understand as
somebody who voted to create this office
um we put in a two-year Sunset because
we do know uh we wanted to try out see
how it worked I think there are some
significant problems with the office as
drafted and the fiscal note would just
extend the office for two years and I'm
not willing to extend an office that I
think is fundamentally flawed um it
either needs more funding so that we can
give him the staff that he needs um or
we need to go back to the drawing board
so I can't vote in favor of this motion
all right anyone else wish to be heard
on yeah uh similar comments to
representative Alexander it seems to me
that we need an ombudsman's office that
acts as an ombudsman uh and the the way
it is currently structured uh the
Ombudsman is not able to act as an
ombudsman he's merely able to act as an
arbitrator I think that we either need
to restructure so that it is better
funded and and differently organized uh
or we need to uh itl the bill and if
we're moving on this right now I will I
shall be it telling recommending that
anyone else wish should be heard
representative Perez I agree that it
needs to be
revamped 100% but I don't believe that
that requires more money I think it
requires just um revamping it and
rewarding it so I'm opposed to putting
more money into it we can't afford it so
anyone else wish to be heard so I guess
here here's my as I I think I've said
this before um this bill is going to go
to
finance I I don't have particularly
strong objections to the Views that have
been expressed by representative
McFarland and representative
Alexander um I tend to agree with
representative Perez that I'm not sure I
would be willing to put more money into
this and I'm quite sure that Finance is
going to have an issue with that but on
the
policy on the
policy question that's sort of before us
right now
I I think it would send the wrong
message to say to people um in the
public that the
the this this committee doesn't support
um the right to no on budsman
because I think from what we heard at
the hearing there are really different
views on whether the ombudsman
um no I don't think there's any question
that that it would be better if the
udman had more resources but even with
the udman operating the way it is it
seems to me that there were different
views on whether um the
udman keeping the udman or getting rid
of the udman is a is a wise move I know
that you know right to know New
Hampshire and those people on those we
heard from those groups they seem to say
it was you know it was better let's keep
the UN
and I know and I think this is something
that's important it's obviously not a
scientific study uh but the
representative from the judicial branch
did note that in the relative in a year
year and a half whatever it's been that
the Ombudsman has been in place there
have been a reduction in filings of
right to know appeals in the superior
court and bear in mind that that it
costs a lot more money um and I and I
think most of the time anyway takes a
lot more time uh to have right to know
matters adjudicated in before the courts
than uh before the than before the udman
so I'm gonna I'm going to be voting in
favor of the uh the
otpa even though you know candidly if if
it when this goes to finance if Finance
decides to kill this for the money
issues I'm I'm not gonna you know that's
I'm not going to be shedding too many
tears but I will be voting for the otpa
uh anyone else representative Smith
thank you very much Mr chair um you've
heard me say this before and you'll hear
me say this again I hope I don't shock
anyone life is not
perfect and what we're trying to do here
is the best we can do with the tools
that are
available I don't know of anyone who
thinks that the concept of an ombudsman
is on its face wrong for the citizens of
this
state do I think we've gotten it all
right absolutely not and it's probably
not the only Bill on this list where we
don't get it all right but I think it's
very important and I support the
Chairman's view that the message we want
to send is that the concept of an um man
is is the right concept for the State of
New Hampshire and it is not perfect we
but the
current I believe has been working very
hard to do his best and I think the
least we should do is continue that
effort so I not thinking this is perfect
at all do intend to support it anyone
else wish to be heard on uh the mo yes
representative McFarland just just one
followup um and that is to your point um
I I think we can all appreciate that
this is saving us money in the court
system uh and so when we're talking
about whether or not we should be
prepared as a body to contemplate
additional funds into the ombudsman's
office we should be understanding that
it's offsetting that cost in the court
system uh which we've already discussed
is overbed
so you know I don't regard it as being
new spending I regard it as being a
question of can we shift and be more
efficient in our spending I appreciate
what you're saying yes representative
horon um well this this amount of money
I mean it may be enough so Finance cuts
it when they're scrambling around to get
a budget together luckily you're
probably thankful Mr chairman you're not
on that committee and the ranking member
probably feels that way too but anyway
yeah this is amazingly actually low
price for for what we're getting and
we're not and considering how little
resources we're doing he seems to be
doing a fine job so seems to be money
well spent so I guess it's it's a
bargain in the larger scheme of things
so I'd like to keep it going for two
more years anyone else wish to be heard
on the uh on the motion uh on the otpa
motion all right um hearing none I guess
we're ready for a vote on uh and the
motion is uh otpa with the uh rep
representative kav's Amendment that's
already
passed representative Manion yes
representative Alexander
nope representative trip yes
representative Andress yes
representative kout yes representative
Perez yes clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
no representative Smith yes
representative Horgan yes represent
restive Harvey yes representative
Raymond yes representative Manos yes
representative tur yes representative
Rambo yes and representative burgon yes
thank you and the chair
clerk get it I vote Yes chairman Lynn
yes that's 15 y two
Nays that right I think that's
right yes all right
um all right and so this is this is
going to finance so it can't go on
consent anyway um uh representative
katab can you write the report and I
have it by the end of the day today
thank you all right
um thank you
Mr chair yes um we're doing so well
moving right along here I wonder if you
would consider changing the order of the
bills as they appear before us because
they're here um in an order in which
we're
well never mind I take it back I take it
back all right so um next I would like
to uh turn
to uh and I before we sort of you know
formally ask for motions or anything
like that I'd like to I'd like to have a
discussion about HB 66 FN and hb40 and
hb7 74 and I'd like to have the
discussion um General I just I want to
get a sense of how the committee feels
so I I guess what what I would do is I
would start
off and what I would say is
this my my caucus and again I'm if if
I've misstated this somebody will will
correct me but I think my caucus would
say that we would be prepared to vote
for House Bill
66 as it is now that would
mean um the for lack of a better term
the broadest possible disclosure
availability under the right to no law
and and the the three the three things
that it would do is first it would
change the references in the right to no
law that mentioned citizen it would
change that to say person so it would be
any person not any citizen um the second
thing um that it would do and this is
kind of really a minor thing the the it
would allow it would provide it would
specifically say that if you have
preliminary
um preliminary drafts that are
circulated to a quorum of a of a commit
of a committee or board at a meeting
those are subject to the right to no law
as we heard in testimony those are
really subject to the right to no law
already but representative Edwards felt
and I thought he was right on this that
it it probably helps to emphasize it by
putting it right in that particular
place where you're talking about this I
think it I think it uh it it makes sense
to do that um the next thing uh
substantively that that 66 does is it
says that you can request records
remotely in other words you don't have
to go to the you know the town offices
or the State offices you can request
records remotely and if you make a
request remotely and ask that the
records be provided electronically the
the governmental entity has to comply
with that and has to provide them in the
format that you request as if they have
the records in that format um uh and if
it would not be unduly burdensome for
them to provide the records to you in
that format um or you know or if it
would not in any way interfere with the
security of their recordkeeping system
um but if those those things are true
then the M then the municipality or the
state has to provide that
information
um it
I I think I I'm really sort of torn
because on one level I like the idea of
having it be as broad as
that what that you know we what that
means however is you know we use we use
the example somebody that you know
somebody in China that is sitting in
their bedroom in their pajamas at
midnight that decides they want all the
records of
communications um uh among the employees
of the town of Windam can do that and
say send them to me electronically and
the town of Windam would have to respond
and that's can be more than I mean
unless they unless they had a legitimate
basis like it's it's overly burdensome
or whatever um they unless they had a
basis they would have to respond
I recognize that
that's that could
be quite
burdensome I I
think that as as representative Smith
and I believe representative Perez
pointed out during the hearings on this
um although that is true it doesn't seem
like there's been a lot of those kind of
and I don't I use China as you know
that's the extreme example but it
doesn't seem like there's been a ton of
those kind of requests from out of state
but or out of the country but there have
been some I mean we got an email from uh
Portsmouth saying that it got one at
least one from Argentina somebody in
Argentina so it's not to say that there
are none
um
so my our the Republican caucus could
support 66 as as drafted but if there is
a concern and I completely understand
the concern I
have an amendment which has been passed
out to all of you which is
amendment uh
110110 and this
amendment amends only section four of
the original Bill and as if you look at
at it what you'll see is that in
subsection a of the
amendment it imposes a requirement that
the
that the person who is
making
um the request without physically
appearing must have a New Hampshire
Connection in the sense that they are
either domiciled in New Hampshire own
property in New Hampshire pay New
Hampshire taxes maintain a place of
business in New Hampshire are or are
registered to do business in New
Hampshire or if you're a member of the
media that the that New Hampshire
connection doesn't apply but those
restrictions would apply if you're
making the request without physically
appearing so if we if we adopted this
amendment what that would mean in my
example the person in China if the
person in China wanted to come to
plastow to the town offices and say I
want all the communications they could
do that but if they want to send an
email saying U send all the records from
you know of Communications in plast out
they couldn't do that they would have to
come personally people that live people
that that
um that want to come personally they
there's no restriction on them but if
you're if you're asking for remote
production um then you have to uh you
have to have a New Hampshire uh
connection um and subsection B Just the
the key word here
is s the word such and in subsection B
at the election of such person that is
the person that owns is domiciled in New
Hampshire has B does business etc etc
those people can ask that the records um
uh be provided in the in the way that um
that they
request everybody who who who comes to
who's willing to come physically to the
town can can get um can get the records
whether you live in China or not
so this it seems to me this you know we
heard the testimony from um is it Mr
castina is it from the school boards
Association
um is it Barrett Christina Christina yes
so he said you know he did say that they
they get like he refer I think he
referred to like some you know some
business entity in California they the
the some school board will get a request
for some information and they'll say um
you know fine I think I think there and
there he
is he um he said that and what and what
they say is you know we have the records
are available the records are available
just come and get them um and and and he
and as he said and I think probably
correctly what that usually means is
they don't come and get because they
don't want them that bad to make a trip
to to New Hampshire to come and get them
so that is a you know that is an if we
adopt this amendment that is an
effective way to limit who is going to
be making the requests for remote
production
um and I can live with
that
I you know I just I mean it's some sense
it's it's contrary to the spirit of the
right to no law in the sense that the
right to no law we're not supposed to be
discouraging people from getting records
and we're not supposed to be concerned
about why they want the records um this
is a little contrary to that but but
there I can see there you know that
they're maybe we don't want people in
China sitting around in their pajamas
asking to you know the town of plastow
to provide all their records so I can I
can live with either one of either with
the amendment or without the amendment
and I ask for your comments uh
representative Smith and then
representative Perez thank you Mr chair
could you just tell me how you would
Define the word
media I would basically Define it
as as you know sort of the same second
it's defined in the statute we defined
it with
102 okay that's no that's true that is
true there is a there is a definition in
there of um yeah but I and I I mean it's
it's pretty broad it's not you know it's
I think you have to what do it say
something
about yeah yes thank you very much as
usual all these younger people have you
know access to the electronic stuff that
leaves me cold you know why while we
waiting for that represent Perez did you
have something comment you want my only
concern is that you have owns property
in New Hampshire pays New Hampshire
taxes literally I could go out to
dinner and pay a tax because we really
don't have any taxes do you want to say
pays real estate taxes literally I could
go out to dinner and say well I paid you
know this tax tax or I went to a state
at a hotel and I played that Tech the
definition of pays ta New Hampshire
taxes since we supposedly don't have any
I have a that's my only concern and it
may be trivial you know you know what no
I mean it's you know I mean you're right
I
guess here's the problem I think with
all with all of this
realistically I suppose you could say
you know if the guy from China had
actually come to New Hampshire and had
dinner and paid well maybe they you know
he is arguably a little bit more worthy
of making the request than somebody who
in China who hasn't done that but not in
pajamas but not in pajamas would make it
even better but but you know the other
thing I think that you point out which I
I think is really
correct even if we adopt this
amendment this is going to be very easy
to get around you know the what what's
the likelihood that somebody in China
who wants to get records electronic Al
isn't going to be able to find somebody
in New Hampshire or somebody you know
somebody somebody in New Hampshire I
guess I would say to make the request
for them and once that person gets the
records there's no restriction the
person can do whatever they know they
can paper their wall with the records
once they get them um so this even if we
adopt this amendment it's it really is
not it's some deterrence but not a huge
deterrence for somebody who really who
really wants the records um so yes
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair just to your point I that's why I
don't think the Amendments needed
because the people that really want the
record are going to find a way to get
around even your Amendment so it just
feels like you know in this committee we
try not to like put too much detail on
91a because we want to leave a lot of it
open to interpretation but I feel like
when we try to Define things like this
like
it I I think if somebody wants to get
the information they'll find a way to
get the information it doesn't matter if
you put guard rails on it or
not that's that's yes representative
H well this is um this issue pertains to
both of these bills more to HB 74 but um
something you did in HB 66 which I think
is good as you crossed out the word
citizen of the state and replac it with
person but um HB
74 tries to come up with the definition
of citizen of the state which I guess
applies only to 91a and um that's I just
think at that moment given what's going
on this is more something that's going
on you know Nationwide then in
Washington DC then conquered um you know
there's a there's a lot of uh debate
about what who is or is not a citizen of
the United States and in state
law I looked at all I tried to did like
a quick search of the rsas um and
there's lots and lots of references to
Citizens most of which don't have uh
most of us just use a whatever the
commonly accepted V word of and there's
some cases uh like with voting you have
to be a citizen of the United States and
domas out of New Hampshire to be uh I'm
not sure if they use the word citizen
but for the purpose of voting so I think
um I think passing HB 74 in any form at
this time is just going to muddy the
water especially given like there's a
debate over the meaning of the 14th
Amendment and you know it's not really
we have enough here to worry about it's
not really our problem but I I don't
think we should uh I don't think we
should be redefining citizen just for
the sake of the right to no law at this
time especially since I'm not really
happy with the the definition so you
know so so you know what can I just make
sure am I understanding Mr uh
representative organ that you would you
would be in favor of just 66 without an
amendment um that too and yes also be
opposed to just HB 74 there maybe okay
there may be some need for Bill I mean
what it should say which is what is
understood that as a citizen of New
Hampshire is a citizen of the United
States who is a domiciled in New
Hampshire and that's uh that would be
probably a good bill that's not really
that's probably not really what we want
to do this morning but I would not okay
I would not pass this amendment this
this change to the law I'm just not
oppose I'm just against changing that
what's in h74 at all so thanks all right
thank you so you know what I'm going to
recognize representative katab because I
think she may have an answer to the
question that was asked by
representative Smith I do and then after
I'd like to ask question if I may thank
you Mr chair um so the the definition of
media is organizations or individuals
who publish information in accepted
digital print or broadcast formats into
standards generally recognized by
professional news organizations that do
not serve primarily as a platform to
promote the interest Andor opinions of a
special interest group government
individual or or cause and that came
from the definition that the New
Hampshire Associated Press uses
essentially
um that's that's in the law now that's
in the law now 91a 91a um
4 ex um I wanted to ask a question if I
may sure so if I'm understanding
correctly the law this bill would be
changing any citizen to any person and
so everybody would be able to access
information exactly as they are now
except it would be any person and the
only place that this doic piece would
apply to would be to those with this new
privilege that we're saying that you can
get these records requested
electronically and you don't have to go
in the into the town hall but it
wouldn't be changing anything else that
already exists it would only be
applicable to this new additional level
of transparency that we're adding is
that is that understanding correct that
no that's correct so just to be very
clear if we pass 66 without the
amendment anybody body there's no
restrict there's no restriction
whatsoever anybody can can request
records and get records remotely if we
pass 66 with the
amendment anybody anywhere will be able
to get records by coming to the physical
location of the of the office you know
where the records are
kept but if you're not somebody that has
a for lack of a better term a New
Hampshire connection or if you're not
somebody that is a member of the media
you can't get the records remotely so
that's the and rep represent tur did you
have a
question yeah thanks um and and uh it
it's it's not related to the the topic
exactly that we've been talking about
this is a question I guess that goes
back to the original bill but I didn't
have it wasn't able to ask it of you
when it was introduced so hopefully it's
okay to ask it now um it's in uh in the
amendment if we're looking at the
amendment it's the the last two lines um
at one time it says no charge shall be
made for records delivered
electronically and then the next line
says the sub paragraph does not preclude
public body from imposing charges
authorized under paragraph 8 my
understanding of paragraph 8 is it does
authorize charges for records um
delivered electronically specifically so
I I it feels like a conflict I wonder if
you could Explain why both of those
sentences are sure so you know what I
think the key word in here is delivered
in other words the I I think the and I
think actually this is in there's some
reference to this in in 102 I think in
other words
we we don't if if if if records are
simply delivered electronically in other
words you you know I the the town sends
them out there can be no charge for the
delivery of the records as such in other
words
the the town couldn't say well look if
we you know if we if we mail these
records to you we could charge you the
postage for mailing them and the C and a
and a charge per page um so we're gonna
try to impose some you know uh
equivalent charge for the delivery in
electronic form but if they meet if it
meets the requirements of of uh
paragraph 8 paragraph 8 that's it's over
250 or whatever I I think
the the way I would look at that is
that's not a charge for the delivery of
the records it's a charge for having to
assemble them and redact them and the
time that's involved and it and yes it's
on a per page kind of thing but it's
really sort of it's not so much that I'm
pressing the button and sending it to
you electronically it's the time that
the
town has to uh has to invol be involved
in doing
this so that that's I would guess so I
guess the question I'm sorry
representative Manos please so I I mean
I guess I the question
is as I said before I can live with
either of these and again let me let me
let me just raise one other thing that I
think again this is what our caucus had
discussed and I think it actually might
be a decent
strategy what we had suggested is let's
pass 66 with without the
amendment and with regard to
74 which has some language about you
know
restricting uh uh some language about
you have to be a a citizen that kind of
thing let's retain
that let's not do anything with that
now if this bill passes the floor which
I think it would without the amendment I
think it would I'm not saying there
wouldn't be some fight over it there
might you know it might be some of
objection but I think 66 would pass the
real issue is what happens when it goes
to the other body there I think there
might be um more push back um and so we
would if it came back and there was some
changes that we didn't like we would
still have S 74 that you know we we
could we could do something with make
appropriate changes to maybe address um
if what what the Senate might have done
um
so you know I guess I'm I'm wondering
what what do people think about that
strategy we passed 66 we retain
74 yes representative mcfar so I I think
first of all I would say that um I hope
that we would all support 66 with or
without the amendment uh when I consider
the question of is it better with the
amendment and your parade of Ables
around the uh pajama clad chinan my
concern is less
around a single request and more around
if somebody like that were to make
thousands of requests and I think for
that reason and also in the spirit of
the right to know uh Law's original
intent I'm supportive of the amendment
um but I I wonder whether it would be
worth taking uh a a feel of the room
yeah for for with and without and and
the other thing I would say is in just
the same way as you're saying Bob that
if we were to uh recommend 66 without
the amendment to to the house floor uh
we could still Rectify it with 74 I
think the same would hold true with the
amendment sure no that's true that's
true so you know I'm sorry uh
representative buron and then
representative
Andrew thank you Mr thank you Mr chair I
was curious to M did municipalities ever
sort of um like for example this might
require a little training for most
municipalities as far as you know what's
legal what's not so I'm curious have we
ever gotten pushed back from changes
like this because I don't know if
they're going have to pay for train oh
yes we have but so just for those for
those of you who are new let let let me
just
spend a brief we
had we we had a huge fight last year um
and it was a bipartisan fight there were
Republicans and Democrats on both sides
of this issue about charging fees for
requests um and um it it went you know
we we initially passed it then um it
there was a a request to recommit it to
the committee it came back to the
committee um I and I forgot what we were
going to do when it came back but
fortunately representative katab and a
former member of this committee uh
representative Kenny um came up with a
with a with what is now uh in in law
that representative kutab was just
referring to that
allows um uh charging for in really a
very limited category of of of uh
Records email Communications if they
exceed 250 in a month one month period
isn't it yeah so it's a very limited uh
number of uh Records that for which
charges can be made but um that's what
we passed so it was there was a huge
issue because I I mean and I think I not
unfairly summarizing many municipalities
wanted the ability to charge because
their position is it takes a lot of time
and a lot of work to gather these
records and
you know why should the taxpayers have
to pay when somebody makes these these
really big requests on the other side
there were people who felt and I
completely understand
this they're public records and you know
where people should be able to get their
records and they shouldn't have to pay
anything and it was a huge fight so um
that's I mean
it's it it that is that has been a big
issue so but I think um representative
Smith
thank you for that explanation if I
could also add one other Factor uh the
cities and towns in New Hamshire um
belong to um the municipal Association
they pay a significant fee uh each of
them to have the municipal
Association uh pay attention to what
we're doing here um try to guide what we
do and you've seen evidence of that but
also provide training um um to uh and
and be a source of information to all
the cities and towns to help make sure
that they have all the information they
need to comply with the law of the state
and that is something that they do and
they've done it for many years and so
the cities and towns are not left out
there to dry on their own and expect you
know the little town the little poor
little town of durm for example to know
about change in laws I mean there are
resources available
to so you know can I just ask I think
representative McFarland had a good can
I just ask can I get just a sense how
how many people would be comfortable
with passing 66 without the amendment
and then retaining 74 can I just ask you
if you're comfortable with that Pat
raise your
hand okay you PR prefer Okay so what are
we got so I'm sorry can I can I ask you
to raise your hand against just so I can
count
yeah this no no no I'm this is this is
not gonna this is not a vote that counts
I'm just trying to get a sense so one
two three four five six seven eight 9 10
11 so uh 12 12 all right the sense is
just to pass 66 to just past 66 right
all right so so there was 12 now how
many would oppose passing 66
without any Amendment so one two three
all
right right
right yeah how many folks would prefer
how many folks would would vote in favor
of Passage with the amendment that's
yeah all right that's right how many
people would favor passage with the
amendment that's so you have to have the
New Hampshire conne passage or vote
passage
what what how many
let me start again how many people would
vote for passage of 66 without the
amendment if you would raise your
hand so what do we got one two three
four
five five six 78 nine so it looks like
nine how many people would vote for 66
with the amendment
sounds like there's slightly more people
that would favor the
amendment um all right so what I'm going
to do then is um I will move Amendment
110h is there a second second seconded
by representative trip okay hang
on um
that was a representative trip second
yes okay
all right Mr yes yes representative
Smith Mr chair I had prepared an
amendment on
66 that addresses a number of the issues
that have been of concern to the
committee but listening to the
discussion up until now and respecting
the disperate views I do not plan to
submit
that Amendment uh because I believe that
the approach that's taken under the
amendment now before our
consideration
um attempts to
address the key issues but does
not get hung up in the weeds and my
Amendment had more detail and in the
fullness of time we might want to get to
more detail but not right now thank you
all right so anyone else have anything
they want to say on the amendment yes
representative Manos thank you Mr chair
I I didn't get to speak earlier and I
was seeking recognition so I want to
make some broader points if I can have
some latitude to do that please um I
agree with your changes to the
definition of person so I agree with
that part of it but I have severe
reservations about um
66 I my reservations are that the
concept
of the town or the municipality or the
city having to produce the records on
the expectation that the person in China
will show up and actually collect the
records still
requires an expenditure of time energy
effort expense by the town and municipal
it or city and um I have severe
reservations about that I also um don't
don't can't support the concept of there
being a two-
tiered process here if the records are
available
electronically then then you have to be
have a if I'm understanding this
correctly and and correct me if I'm
wrong if you have a relationship with
the state the and the records are
available in electronic form then you
get them but if you don't have a
relationship with the state or the
records are not available in electronic
form then you have to show up to collect
them am I understanding that correct I
think that oversimplifies it a little
bit if the uh so I if what if the you're
right about the connection with the
state or not connction so let me let me
try to restate it if
you want to get records whether they're
electronic or not if you want to get
records and you are willing to come to
the town to get them you can get anyone
can get the records including the person
in China if they want to come to plastal
you know to get the records whether the
records are kept electronically or not
they can get the records if they're kept
electronically the town can provide them
electronically or the town can provide
them in paper copies but the person can
get the record if you want if if you're
um not someone that has a connection
with New Hampshire under under the amend
then you can't request the records
remotely you can't in other words you if
you don't want to come to New Hampshire
you can't get the records whether
they're kep kept remotely I mean whether
they're kept electronically or not you
have to um but if if you have a
connection with New Hampshire then you
can request the records remotely and you
can ask for the way that they'll be
provided I mean you if if they have they
have them an electronic format you can
get them electronically anyway it it
creates a two-tier system and I'm not
supportive of that and particularly
given that the town Municipality of City
would have to EXP spend the time and
energy to produce the records not
knowing whether the person is going to
show up to collect them or not or that
there is that there's any likelihood a
strong likelihood that they would show
up what I would suggest on this and I
also had an amendment on 74 I prefer
74 um and what I would suggest is that
rather retaining rather than retaining
66 rather than passing 66 and retaining
70 before I would urge that we set up a
working group which I would be happy to
to participate in to see if we can um
uh to for us to work on both of these
bills and see if we can come to
consensus and come to one bill that we
can um support uh as a committee and
send on to the
floor anyone else so um yes uh
representative
I like that idea um I'm new to this
committee but in my committee when we've
discussed a bill for I don't know 45
minutes it's pretty obvious that the
Bill's not quite ready for prime time
and I think that looking at it as a
subcommittee and then coming back with
something that you can present to the
floor with a very strong vote is a good
idea anyone else wish to be
heard yes representative Anders thank
you Mr chair uh as far as the amendment
goes is it
constitutional part one article 8 of The
Constitution talks about people having
access and in there there's the word
public is everybody the public all over
the world I mean in while we TR going
against it and as far as 66 and 74 I am
in favor retaining them because I think
we need to F tune both of them
anyone else wish to be heard
representative
Perez I think we should
leave I think we shouldn't deal with
these the we
passed went through hell to pass 91a and
I'm going to tell you quite honestly the
only reason why I voted in favor of it
on the floor is because the Senate bill
was
worse I we spent forever I think there's
problems with it I still believe that
people should not be charged for but
that's my personal belief we don't know
what the Senate's coming up with I don't
think we should be passing either of
these I think you know we want to let
the ab budsman have another two years to
work maybe we need to let the 91a that
we voted in at least have a year to work
I mean when did we vote it in it hasn't
even been a year
yet yeah so all so you know here's I
guess I I think it's kind of important
to to understand this this
whole citizen thing this citizen uh
issue which this is one of that's one of
the things this is designed to
correct that came up really in one case
and and as the superior Court's decision
sort of pointed out um
there the idea that by changing this to
any person we're sort of you know
really making this big expansion I know
that the you know some of the
municipalities have expressed real
concern about this but other than this
one case as far as we know there was
never any issue raised when out of state
um
uh entities had requested information um
or I guess even when out of apparently
even when somebody from Argentina
requested information there had never
been any issues
until this one uh Town decided that
because a newspaper reporter who lived
in Maine but was reporting on you know
was was reporting on New Hampshire on
the New Hampshire town because they
could try to you know prevent that
person from getting records which I I
have to say it seems completely
outrageous to me only because that that
came up was this whole issue raised so I
I really do think it's it's important to
emphasize
that as a practical matter although yes
there are the you know that guy in China
in his pajamas I suppose you know this
would sort of explicitly allow that
whereas right now you have the
citizenship somebody could make an
argument on that it I don't think it's
much of a real issue and the other point
that I agree with representative Perez
on is it's really important to
understand this whole area has been
looked at we spent a lot of time on it
last year and I with deference to people
who have suggested this I my sense is if
we put this off uh you know to look at
it for we're going to be back with the
same kind of things you know a month
from now or whatever and we got a lot of
bills in this committee so I would tend
to
say let's let's vote on this now now
that's that would be my sense so um with
that I'm going to uh uh I'm going to
I've moved the amendment it's been
seconded and um I'm going to press for a
vote on the amendment does um anybody
else want to speak to the amendment
representative representative Smith the
only uh comment I want to make to my
colleague is that 91a has been the law
for quite a while I think what you meant
is the latest um iteration so we've been
struggling with this since time in
Memorial and it's never been
easy thank and I know you know that
representative anyone yes representative
mcfar I I would just say to those who
are uh on the fence on voting for the
amendment and to the Constitutional
question that was
raised it seems to me that the language
in the
amendment is a far closer match to my
understanding of the public and people
who are choosing to be part of our
social contract uh here in in New
Hampshire uh and in in the government of
New Hampshire uh than uh the current
language with the concerns that Bob
raised around Citizen and and you know
the the the ultimate necessity of
considering how to define that so uh
when when you read in the Constitution
where it says the public I put it to you
that that does not include the uh the
person who lives in Argentina is
domiciled has citizenship in Argentina
and has no Nexus to New Hampshire
whatsoever all right anyone else all
right so the the the uh the motion
before us is on um ought to pass
Amendment
20251 and because it's amendment can I
ask for a show of hands all those in
favor of adopting this amendment please
raise your
hand 13 I count
13 um and all those opposed please raise
your
hand four all right so 13 to four all
right um
all right so now we're on to um o uh the
otpa or I would move otpa on House Bill
66 as amended by Amendment 20250
1110 um anybody have anything further
they want to say on that motion need a
second oh I'm sorry I I need a second do
I have a second second representative
Smith all
right all right
um all right ready for a vote all right
so I would ask the clerk then to call
the role on otpa on House Bill 66
representative Manion yes
representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andress no representative kutab yes
representative Perez no clerk votes yes
representative McFarland yes
representative Smith yes representative
Horgan yes representative Harvey
no representative Raymond yes
representative Manos
no representative tur yes representative
Rambo yes representative berson yes
chairman Lynn
yes 13 y for
nay regular calendar regular calendar
regular calendar who's writing the
report I'm afraid I'm writing the report
all will there be a Minority Report
represent Manos you write the minority
all right um all
right and can you have that to me by
tonight thank you
um Mr chair in order to speed things up
I'm happy to make a motion to retain HP
74 yes I'll second that motion um all
right any would you like to speak to the
motion
no I don't all
right all right um any further
discussion on HB
74 all right um so the motion is to
retain HB
74 um and I would uh ask the clerk when
you're ready and take your time but when
you're ready to uh call the role I'm
representative Manion yes representative
Alexander representative trip yes
representative Andress yes
representative kutab yes representative
Perez yes clerk votes yes representative
McFarland yes representative Smith yes
representative Horgan yes representative
Harvey yes representative Raymond yes
representative Manos yes representative
turer yes representative Rambo yes
representative Bergeron yes and chairman
Lynn
yes 17 yay zero
Nays and we don't need a report right um
we don't need a report on that now uh we
just we just we just yeah we'll all
right so at some point we'll have to do
a report but we don't we don't need a
report until this fall if we can't come
up with anything and recommend interim
study so all right
um all right uh now let me go on to
where
um there's my list ah here we go um all
right
um oh right um yes hang on one second
all right um house bill um 80 allowing a
public body members Presence at a public
meeting only a physical presence is
unavoidable and requiring physical
presence for voting chair recognizes uh
representative Smith
um while I have great respect for
my can't imagine anyone really wants to
hear me so while I have great respect
for my colleague from straford County
and I
understand um his
frustrations um
nonetheless uh I do not believe um that
this bill is is really workable the
definition of um unavoidable
is not clear um uh is that impossible to
prevent what does it mean
um I think that this is an example of
where we have
to understand once again that life is
not perfect and uh and we are not really
able to resolve this problem with this
legislation I'm sorry you know was there
a second to the to the
motion second by representative Oregon
all right so no I'm sorry that's all
right um all right um all right anyone
else uh wish to wish to speak to yes
representative or um well we had a
straford county budget meeting um rep I
was President Reverend Smith had an
excused absence and we had a member um
we actually had a somewhat ironic thing
we had a member who was out of state for
reasons that are unavoidable it was
family business required her to be about
1,500 miles away and she
unfortunately tried to zoom into the
meeting but was unable to because the uh
person who was operating the waiting
room forgot to no she's in the waiting
room which is not really an argument for
against this pill but it just shows uh
you just shows that Zoom is an important
uh important way of extending people's
access to the meeting because otherwise
that member would have been totally un
would wouldn't even had a chance to
attend the meeting so I mean so
certainly um or public bodies when they
use zoom for voting like you know have
to make sure it works right it's still a
new thing but uh yeah I think uh but I
think I think um you know we we should
be they should be allowed to use zoom so
I think I think what we have is not
perfect but it's working pretty well
though not necessarily well last night
but thanks
and I add all the all the votes we took
were unanimous anyway so it didn't
affect the result of the vote the
problem we had all right uh
representative Perez thank you I noticed
when you talked you used the term
unavoidable when you talked about a
person being out of state I think the
term unavoidable is much more easily
defined than not reasonably practical so
so I really think that
unavoidable has a definite definition as
a word if you look it up in the
dictionary but not reasonably practical
does not have a definition so as far as
the
voting I agree that you should have to
be present to a vot to vote but you know
I would let that go but changing the
wording to me is very very important
so other yes representative trip the uh
main issue I have with this bill is uh
it applies to every public body and uh
you know this is this is painting with a
broad you know brush that uh was will
have unintended
consequences other yes representative
kop well I do agree that the term
unavoidable would probably be much more
easily understood by the public my real
concern with this bill is that while
it's not allowing somebody to vote it is
allowing them to count towards the
Quorum of the body and we need to
remember that again this is where the
broad brush applies to every body and
there are quite a few towns where their
bodies are only three member bodies and
so essentially what this would mean is
that if one person happens to be absent
one is present at the location and one
is on the phone then that means then the
person that's present at the location
that one person will be the sole
deciding person on everything and the
person on the phone I mean you might as
well just say it's not an emergency
meeting you can't have the meeting it
just it doesn't make sense to allow one
person to make a decision on everybody's
behalf representative Alexander thank
you Mr chair um I I agree with
representative cab I would be in favor
of this bill if we scratch section two
and just renumber it and add just do the
change of not reasonably practical to
unavoidable so my position on the floor
would be ought to pass with an amendment
that would just drop section two um for
the purposes of voting but I think there
is some merit with changing not
reasonably practical to unavoidable all
right other anyone else yes thank you Mr
chairman um so as many of you may or may
not know I've been on the board of
education in Nashville for quite some
time in my first two years on the board
we had a gentleman Mr moer um who had
suffered a stroke um his attendance for
two years we voted all the time was to
be via the phone he didn't count towards
the Quorum um and he probably could have
made it in if someone had picked him up
at his house and driven it wasn't
unavoidable for him not to go but it was
really inconvenient and while he was
mentally extremely fit physically he was
not and the process of getting into
someone else's car and then having to
walk into the building and walk down the
slope and sit in the the you with the
rest of us was difficult for him I I
would hate to see someone like a Mr moer
miss his chance to participate in the
process after having been elected um
because of a change in wording like this
I could certainly see someone arguing
that it is not unavoidable he should
just use his walker and come to the
meetings um and I can tell you as a new
member you know eight years ago hearing
from someone who had been on the board
for 20 years about how things had been
done about his thoughts on pretty much
every topic that we discussed was
extremely helpful and I again I would
hate to see a change like this have an
unintended consequence of taking someone
who has something that isn't practical
for them to come but is probably
avoidable thank you anyone else wish to
be heard so I guess what yes
representative HG well I'll just respond
to the uh point to General Le he made
which I did use the word unavoidable I
was not trying to imply that I thought
that was a better language than not
reasonably practical in either case um
when a member of you know of any public
body wishes to use that remote option I
think we should respect their reasons
for doing so so she would not second
guess second uh should not be second
guessing them so if somebody says it's
not reasonably practical uh unless
they're very grossly abusing it um we
should respect the fact that it's not
reasonably practical and if we change it
unavoidable there'll still be the same
thing we still have to respect their
reasons for thinking it was unavoidable
for them to show up and you know there
may be some cases where theoretically in
fact that was like the dispute that
prompted this Builder so like
theoretically the member who
participated by Zoom
theoretically could have could have like
driven a very long distance to get here
and back but it was better for him not
to and I I respect I respect that
particular member's decision certainly
in any case almost every case it's it's
preferable to have a member
participating remotely and voting and
joining discussion than in not having
them there at all sure it's better it's
nice to have them there in person but if
they can't make it in person but they're
still ready to address the issues um
that's better than just having them sit
at home and not be able to do anything
about it at all so
thanks right anyone else wish should be
heard so I guess I'm I'm persuaded to
vote itl on this for one basic reason it
seems to me this really is a matter of
local control I mean it may if if local
boards as as representative trip uh I
think Point points out this this would
apply everywhere and it seems to me if
local boards don't want to do if they
want to have if they want assisted
people be there you know you have you
can't come remotely they can do that
nothing prevents them from doing that if
they want to make say you know you have
to if you want to vote you have to be
there they can do that but I it just
seems to me why you know what's
the what's the interest in that the fact
that you know the with great respect for
the sponsor of the bill who I have the
utmost respect for but you know the fact
that it
you the the vote sort of didn't go your
way I mean the you know your desire to
have the the system work in a certain
way in your locality and you lose the
vote on that that's you know that's what
democracy is about so I guess I I'm I'm
persuaded to to support the itl motion
anything else anyone wishes to
say all right I guess we're ready for um
a roll call vote on the motion of
itl Representative Manion
yes who seconded that uh representative
sorry I just want to make sure sure sure
no
problem sorry representative Manion yes
representative Alexander no
representative trip yes representative
Andrew yes Representative
kutab no representative
Perez
representative clerk votes no
representative McFarland yes
representative he's here representative
Smith yes representative Horgan yes
representative Harvey yes representative
Raymond yes representative Manos yes
representative tur yes representative
Rambo yes and representative Bon
yes and chairman Lynn
yes 13 yays 14 nays I'm sorry what oh
four sorry oh my gosh itl 13 to4 we'd
never get anything done if there were
that many people in um uh
represent will there be a Minority
Report um I'll I'll let you know by the
end of today I think okay I I think the
The Minority Report if there is one
would be otpa but I don't know what
other committee members that voted the
minority thing so okay all right so
representative Smith you'll do the uh
majority we'll go on the regular regular
C yes regular calendar
um uh all right so hang on one second
um that was a lot of time then you'll
let me know by the end of the day you
said Joe on the okay I represent
Alexander I'm sorry 80
um 13
[Music]
no represent
SMI all right um next uh we're on to uh
HB 265 and the chair recognizes
representative uh kab for a
[Music]
motion I move on to pass J second
second moved by representative katab
seconded by representative Smith uh
representative kab do you speak to your
motion uh no I think this is just uh
sure real quick I guess because there's
Subs here just to explain this is just a
really simple Bill to add in the start
and end times and the the name of the
person doing the minutes the reason why
is because this has been challenged that
these were not official minutes and so I
think it's really important that we
identify who was taking the minutes so
that people know that they were in fact
official minutes thank
you anyone else wish to say anything on
HB uh
265 all right seeing none um I'd ask the
clerk to call the role the motion is OTP
on House Bill 6 uh 265 representative
Manion yes representative Alexander
representative trip yes representative
Andress yes representative kutab yes
representative Perez
clerk votes yes representative McFarland
yes representative Smith representative
Horgan yes representative Harvey yes
representative Raymond yes
representative Manos yes representative
tur yes representative Rambo yes
representative berson yes chairman Lynn
yes 17 y zero Nays all right uh anybody
have an objection to going on
consent all right will'll be on consent
and um representative katab can you
write the uh report right thank thank
you
um all
right um all right um next
um I'd like to
um turn to uh
hb14 um FN and uh the chair recognizes
representative tur for a
motion uh thank you Mr chair I'd like to
make the motion of itl on House Bill 114
is there a second I'll second seconded
by representative uh Smith
uh Smith uh representative tur would you
like to speak to your motion sure
briefly um I think we've already talked
about all the um efforts and discussions
and time that went into crafting house
build 102 in the last session um it's a
relatively new change to the law we're
still looking at the impacts of that um
this essentially rolls back all that
effort um and uh I don't feel that
that's appropriate uh given given the
the combination of effort and and lack
of experience with the with the new rule
all
right representative Andress do you wish
to uh to speak on this I I I know I know
that technically your amendment is not
before us but I think In fairness I we
it it it I think it goes your
your your this is your bill and I think
the amendment it sort of goes to what
we're discussing so I'd like to hear
what you have to say about it so should
I introduce the amendment now or I don't
think we should introduce the amendment
now but you can certainly talk about
talk about if we if we ever got to that
Amendment what it would say all
right the only reason I am against the
current
law last year I realized there was much
discussion much
work but this was all about a few places
like one was Rochester one was down in
some other part of the Southern
State and the
average every day citizen in the state
of New Hampshire was not considered
whether any one of us like it or not
there are people that have a right to
know about their
government and they do not have the
money and they may have to ask for a lot
of information but they don't have the
money to pay and this bill the current
law should be done away
with I had an amendment and what it was
is to put the liability back in the bill
because I gave it that a lot of thought
and as far as municipalities go and even
school districts because I've had a lot
to do with them I don't think anybody
would
honestly cheat and not give you the
information that you asked
for but again we live in a live free a
die State and yet what I find the law
that took effect last
year is taking away the people's rights
in the state of New Hampshire thank you
anyone else wish to be heard
representative tur uh just want one
clarification there were a few very
high-profile issues of uh very broad uh
right to know requests um that that
became publicized the issue I think was
a lot more widespread than that I know
it was an issue in my community ones
around mine um and um you know there
were provisions put in to protect people
unable to pay um so I I just didn't want
to characterize it as as as a change
that was made without um a a lot of um
input from places that that were
experiencing these problems and it was
made to really protect the right to no
law from uh the abuses that were taking
place all right um yes representative
Perez I just want to reiterate I only
voted for it I did not want charges I
only voted in favor of it because the
Senate bill was
worse anyone else so I guess what I
would say is that oh I'm sorry
representative
McFarland I I'm in favor of both the
underlying bill and the amendment
however I would ask Mr chairman if we
could perhaps get the the the sense of
um the uh representative Andress
introducing the amendment here um with
regard to the desire to strike from the
original Bill
language um sorry let me rephrase in the
original Bill language we strike
paragraphs E and
F and in the amended language we only
strike in that section
e it's not clear to me why we need to
strike e at all I understand that we're
changing uh the statute if we adopt this
so that there is no cost or fee to the
request
but there is a cost to the agency the
town you know the government entity and
I don't find it
unreasonable that a town might say hey
you've asked for XYZ could you maybe
accept x y and B uh and that would save
us us funds and I suspect that many
taxpayers making such a request would be
happy to acceed to that so is there a
particular reason why we need to strike
paragraph e i i that's a that's I guess
that's really a question to you
representative
Andrew I'm not sure how to answer it so
I'm not going to right so so here's you
know here here's what I guess as my sort
of opportunity to speak on this I really
think and I would urge the committee to
support the itl motion on this and for
this reason as I said
before this with or without the
amendment this bill effectively would
repeal uh house bill one2 from a year
ago that as I indicated this was the
subject of great contention in the house
and the senate representative uh katab
and rep former representative Kenny were
able to come up with uh an amendment
that that you know it was a classic
amendment that both sides of the issue
were you know had some unhappiness with
um as representative Perez says you know
she sort of voted for it because the
what was what the Senate was proposing
to do would have been worse um I frankly
was on the other side of that issue from
representative perz I would have imposed
I would have wanted to impose uh give
towns the ability to impose costs in
more situations um but it was a you know
it was a compromise that we worked out
and the other thing that I think is
really really important to understand is
the testimony we heard in
this the current law says that even the
the very small ability to recover fee
recover costs if you have over 250
emails in uh uh in a month if you're
requesting that can only be done by a
municipality or the state I guess but it
can only be done if you've adopted
guidelines or policies to to to allow
you to do that the testimony we heard
was that no municipalities had done that
so no Municipal you know so the idea
that municipalities are are improperly
charging people for uh fees to to uh
even Under The Limited ability they have
it it's not happening I mean we didn't
hear any evidence suggesting that you
know this this person was charged some
outrageous amount of money for E for
because they asked for too many emails
so I urge you
this the we we spent a great deal of
time last year arriving at a
compromise the compromise Ser the
compromise you know everybody had to
swallow hard but we did it um and it
certainly hasn't been in effect the the
the current law certainly hasn't been in
effect long enough that we can say well
it's not
working because no nobody really I mean
it's having even as a practical matter
it hasn't even really been implemented
because towns haven't adopted the
guidelines so right now they're not
charging so for all those reasons I urge
everyone to vote
itl anyone
else all right um I guess we're ready
for uh a vote the motion is uh on hb14
FN
itl representative Manion yes
representative Alexander
no representative trip yes
representative Andrew no representative
kab yes representative Perez
no clerk votes yes representative
McFarland
no
representative
Smith representative Horgan yes
representative Harvey yes representative
Raymond representative Manos yes
representative tur yes representative
Rambo yes and representative buron
yes and chairman Lynn
yes all right no
problem 13 y four
Nays
four um all than see is um so
representative tur will you prepare the
uh majority report and is there going to
be a Minority Report yes I'll one all
right oh question though it has to be in
by
tonight yeah even if get here can get
here it can get here late tonight but as
long as I come up tomor I I don't go to
bed till midnight is that too late no
that's fine that's
fine majority all right majority is sure
and the minority is
Andrew Andrew
okay all right
um 313 um no that's we're gonna that's
the one that we um there we had a sub
committee you were gonna wait for Paul
and Paul and who was who was Joe you
were excuse me representative Alexander
you were working with representative
Birch on a on H HB 313 I believe I
volunteered representative Burch and
Rich uh representative trip volunteered
himself oh so we'll be we'll be working
on that while you're away and hopefully
come that's fine that's fine good all
right
um all right um next I turn to um House
Bill uh 376 specifying that Library user
information exempt from disclosure under
the right to no law includes information
regarding library cards and Library
membership status chair recognized
representative Alexander for a motion
thank you Mr chair I move on to pass
there
second all right seconded by
representative Perez uh representative
Alexander do you wish to speak to your
motion yes briefly it's very important
libraries serve as vital Community
Resources providing access to
information in a safe and private
environment however under current
interpretations of RSA 91a library card
holder information could be made
publicly accessible which raises serious
privacy
concerns library cards are personal
tools used to borrow books and access
services details that should not be
subject to public scrutiny the language
in HB 376 is clarifying language so that
the release of library card user
information is clearly in violation of
RSA 91a releasing such information
undermines an individual's right to
privacy and could discourage people from
using libraries altogether moreover
libraries are trusted to safeguard
personal data and releasing this
information would be violation of that
trust exempting library card records
from Public Access aligns with privacy
protections found in other sectors
ensuring libraries remain safe spaces
where individuals can explore knowledge
without fear of exposure right to know
New Hampshire supports this clarifying
language please vote for it thank
you you know what I'm you know I'm I'm
sorry representa Alexander did you I
didn't you had an amendment um is that
you did oh you do not I don't have an
amendment to this okay no ought to pass
as it is okay as ought to pass as it is
all right right anyone else wish to be
heard on HB
376 all right then I think we're ready
for uh vote I'd ask the clerk to uh call
the role and the motion is uh ought to
pass representative Manion yes
representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew yes representative kutab yes
representative Perez yes clerk votes yes
representative McFarland yes repres
representative Smith yes representative
Horgan
no representative Harvey yes
representative
Rond representative Manos
yes was that a no a yes that was a yes
sorry representative tur yes
representative Rambo yes representative
Bon yes and chairman Lynn
yes 16 yays one nay
all right um can that go on the
regular uh I think I I would say I would
say consent unless somebody objects
anybody object to
consent I can live with consent I just
voted no because it was unnecessary but
okay all right uh and representative
Horan I'll call you later about
that all right and um representative
that's not Liv represent representative
Alexander can you write the uh report
all right it's already
right Alexander all right Alexander okay
um all right
um all right uh 273 um relative to
parents access to their minor child's
library cards uh the chair recognizes
representative Perez for a motion I move
ought to pass is there a second I second
all right moved by representative Perez
seconded by representative pno
representative Perez you wish to speak
to your motion yes very briefly because
we did talk about this we're talking
about children we're talking about
children under the age of 18 we're
talking about their safety we're talking
about parents who can't
get find out what books their children
are taking out but yet if the book is
lost or it's late they have to be
responsible without knowing what they're
paying for for paying for
this I think it's a common sense thing I
think you know as much as you want to
might want to say that they have a right
to privacy under the age of 18 yes they
have a right to privacy for some things
but certainly not on material these kids
can get this information on the
internet there's no reason why the
parents can't know what books they're
trying to take out of the library it's
common sense I believe it's a parent
right and I hope that you will pass it
all right anyone else wish to be heard
on uh rep house on a motion of V to pass
yes representative yes please thank you
Mr chairman um so this bill randomly
went to Child and Family Law last
session and child and family law uh
recommended against passage and we
recommended against passage last year
for a couple of different reasons um
first if a parent wants to have
unfettered access to the records of
their child the solution already exists
you simply have the child use the
parents library card which they are able
to do until they are 18 so that would
allow the parent to see everything that
their child has checked out and have all
that information Our concern about a
parent getting access to the child's
Library Records Was regarding a lot of
thorny child custody and child abuse
things that libraries aren't prepared to
track so this bill kind of addresses it
and I appreciated that because it says
if the parent has the same license
address as the child however we know in
child and family law that
frequently people move in and out of
households and no one ever updates their
library card address so it is very
possible that there will be situations
where a parent has a court order saying
that they do not have rights to
information about this child due to
their own behavior but their physical
license might still match and that might
still match overlap for years not just
days so again I think that this is a
solution in search of a problem and if
parents want to know what their kids are
reading in the public library the
solution is to use one library card that
is in the parents name and we had dozens
of librarians from across the state
testify that in fact that is a practice
that happens in all of the libraries in
New Hampshire you know at this point I'm
going to take a brief recess and call a
uh uh Republican caucus uh for five
minutes all right so we'll take a brief
recess
e
e e
I'm going to re uh reopen the executive
session we're on uh House Bill uh
um the motion is ought to pass anybody
else wish to be heard on uh the motion
of ought to pass yes
representative um I spoke at the hearing
when this bill came up and I stand by
those comments
um yes we're talking about children but
children don't always live at the same
dress as their parents they children are
in foster care children live with
boyfriends children are homeless so just
because the person in front of me says
says that he lives at a certain address
which really should be verified in some
way that's not um defined in this bill
is does not mean that the children live
at that same address um and to expect a
library staff member to have that
information at their finger tips is is
expecting way too much right anyone else
wish to be heard on yes representative
pno thank you chairman Lynn um I spoke
with or received an email from um former
representative arene corello who spoke
here and she's a librarian and she said
that she linked Accounts at the Raymond
library but it didn't give her the
ability to tell parents what books their
kids had out it just allowed all family
accounts to appear appear on one
computer screen which made checking
books in and out quicker and easier
linking accounts was done by request
only only from parents it didn't just
happened automatically and in the end it
didn't bypass the current state
law and I also this just seems to be um
a fundamental right and Duty and
obligation of parents to be able to
manage the books that their children
have out of the libr out from the
library anyone else wish to be heard um
I I have to say I'm I I intend to
support this it it it really seems to me
that this is just you know one more
indication of uh of uh entities of
government and particularly troubling to
me is schools are basically you know
cutting the parents out of the uh of uh
of having information that they it
fundamentally should should be available
to them so I intend to support the OTP
motion anyone else wish to be heard
representative Perez just a quick thing
we had a very and there's many of them
but a very unfortunate thing we had an
extremely suicidal Middle School
depressed suicidal parents were doing
everything they could everything they
could and that child was encouraged to
take out a book about the pros and cons
of
suicide their parent that parent had no
right to know about that but fortunately
the
child brought it to the parents this
type of inappropriate thing can happen
parents have a right to know what as
books are being given to their children
or taken out of a library by their
children anyone else wish to be heard
yes represent representative bur thank
you as many of you know I I'm on the
board of the Manchester School District
so I've always felt like our students
should be able to have access to the
library without their parents knowledge
just on certain books in the event that
they're actually looking into a topic
that they can't speak to their parents
about or Guardian whatnot so after
talking to many students I'm saying to
myself they deserve the Privacy right
anyone else wish to be heard on uh HB uh
all right seeing none I'd ask the uh
clerk to call the role in the motion
before us is uh representative Perez
motion ought to pass representative
Manion yes representative Alexander yes
representative trip yes representative
Andrew yes representative cutab yes
representative Perez yes clerk votes yes
representative McFarland yes
representative
Smith representative Horgan no
representative Harvey
no representative
Raymond representative Manos no
representative tur no representative
Rambo no representative berson
yes I'm
sorry that's contrary to what you just
said right okay um yeah I I approved
this you want to pass this you you're
moving okay what
yeah I want to not give them
access oh okay so all right
no are you changing your vote Yes I am
changing my vote thank you is changing
his
V and chairman L go ahead and
laugh sorry yeah I vote Yes
nine Ys nine nine Ys eight
Nays okay so um on to pass uh
representative representative Perez will
you write the report all right uh by
tonight
yes by
midnight
majority will be a Minority Report and I
believe representative R will um write
the report
represent rbo by by tonight even if it's
late thank you I think we're all
night all right so let me just let me um
I you know I in the interest of trying
to get us uh as much work out of the way
as we can let me just ask about the
bills that we
heard yesterday so I'm uh I'm sure that
you know
I'm not going to try to have a uh I I'm
sure there will be significant uh
disagreement on hp19 on the F statute
limitations um with regard to
HB
everybody to extend the statute of
limitations to say I I don't agree I
certainly I certainly
don't
um yeah yeah um
all right uh on 268 representative Manos
uh the uh we I know you said yesterday
you wanted to think a little bit about
the board of tax and land appeals uh if
you if you haven't had enough time I'm
not going to say we have to do it but if
you have we could do
it okay all right um we've taken we've
exacted the EXE the uh um at HP 337 and
uh um representative buron just make
sure you get back to me with if you if
you agree on that report um rep uh what
about HB
369 um that's the sexual assault uh
changing the process for sexual assault
misdemeanor cases um again I'm not going
to I Just Want to Have a brief
discussion rather than rather than
taking a vote yet but um representative
kutab can you just tell us you have a
proposed amendment um which I guess I'm
sorry I don't think I've passed out yet
un unless you are passing passing that
way all right coming this way all right
so there so this amendment just simply
corrects the issue that we heard
yesterday it's saying a victim less than
18 years of age in both places at the
time that the prosecution is commenced I
did also run this by the prosecutor that
was here yesterday he was happy with
this language he felt like it should be
consistent in both places and has less
than instead of years or less that might
become ambiguous or argued later so this
is just
simply changing it from um 16 to 18
there because keeping in mind too that
that will mean essentially that
somebody's 17 if you're less than 18 all
right so um I guess I'm just wondering
where I mean I'm I personally I'm fine
with the amendment and personally I
would be
um prepared to uh EXA the bill and vote
uh
otpa um where where are people where are
people on it I personally fine with the
amendment ATA but obviously I had no
reason to call my Fus
so I need to it can be done openly now I
don't care but I need to know how people
feel so I would appreciate a straw vote
yeah yeah sure so and again I you know
if anyone I I don't want to sort of in
any way ramrod anyone into uh you know
voting if you're uncomfortable but I I'm
wondering could I just ask for a straw a
show of hands for a straw vote if the if
the motion was
otpa with representative kab's Amendment
um who would if you raise your hand if
you would support
that any uh representative fing you're
the appears you're I would support the
amendment I personally would like more
time to understand the underlying Bill
I've listened to the testimony uh but I
haven't reviewed the rsas it relates to
okay no I'm not gonna if if you have you
want more time I say as I said with
representative Manos we won't we won't
exec this today then
um all right and the last one uh that we
that we could exact um is HP 480
relative to uh restoration of
Competency
um uh to stand trial for criminal
defendants and that again there was a
some um if I recall somebody had some
wanted to have more time I thought but
somebody said they needed that wases
that was represented pet I I still I
have not had a chance to review that yet
then no then then we're we're all set um
were you busy
yesterday you have some work to do
yesterday go you're kidding all right
um I think uh I think we're done unless
somebody has uh something else that they
think we need to do all right so um I
would like to thank the substitutes yes
for sure thank you thank you to the
substitutes for being here um
uh
no they won't make it this week they
will
not so
right we have a little bit more to
discuss here yeah hang on everyone yeah
hang on just
one so uh everybody so every you
everybody knows their report the
reporting assignments you're going to
get them to me by the end of the night
uh please do that because I've got there
uh I I I I want to get these out and I
get them on the calendar and do the
because I'm going on a trip yes um all
right anything else that we need to
discuss anything else anybody wants to
discuss yes and it looks like the looks
like the 20th also you'll be having out
right right
um uh all right um so oh I'm sorry you
know what the only other thing I wanted
to say is just uh we're we now with the
hearings we're having on Monday we will
have scheduled all the bills that have
been uh scheduled for hearing all the
bills that are are before us um but we
won't have exact all an awful lot of
them so I I guess all I'm all I want to
make sure everybody understands is in
early March we're going to be quite busy
uh we're probably going to have to have
more we're going to meet more than one
day a week probably to get these the
bills exact so be you know buckle up
what time is I
realiz on the third on Monday it's n
start we start at 9:30 start
9:30 okay all right all right uh
anything
else all right thank you very much thank
you
wow for